[Music]
so what do you think should we do let's
make a quick little app this isn't going
to do much for us right we just have our
blank app
but what do you think like an input and
a button i think
i think just a plain button and uh maybe
some text output and it'll be like
random dice roll
like
um
and this is actually going to lead up to
uh one of the um
first couple weeks when i was working
with joe on like reactivity
and it's like we're going to get to this
deduping
random dice rolls
so
yeah okay so we're going back we're
about going back to the good old days
yeah
all right until the action button is
perfect and then the text output you're
thinking
like a verbatim text output maybe okay
just to have it look code like
and then
we'll add a label to the button oh yeah
roll dice or something
nice all right are we gonna do more than
one
is it singular
wouldn't we roll the die
ah it just sounds so weird it does
so again we're gonna skip over making
this beautiful and go straight into
the programming logic
absolutely
i i like how you understand me
[Music]
all right so this is a super fun game
it's going to roll the dice and it's
going to give us some kind of output um
and then we're going to work in
different ways to do this okay
so we would traditionally in our server
function we would want some kind of like
output um
code like text
and then what how do you want to
approach this what do you want to do
let's do um
render text and say
like
dice of dice vowel like a reactive which
is called diceval so oh okay so you're
saying dice val
yep and then let's make dice val as a
there's a reactive outside of
um 14.
yeah
somewhere before
yeah
so we've got our reactive value so this
is our this is the value of our dice aka
single die but all right it's fine
that's fine
um
and then that itself is dice val open
close and 17. mm-hmm
and
14 weeks instead of a reactive vowel we
could probably shorten it to just a
reactive
okay that listens to
um it yeah it has a curly bracket on the
inside and and it listens to like what
input
dollar button zero one
yes so
input
oh okay wait i screwed up my formatting
sorry
oh oh uh
right uh it's no it's all uh it can be
multi-line i like multi-line
um
yeah input dollar okay button one
there we go so that's what we're
listening and then
we're listening to it but the actual
thing that we're doing um uh after line
15 inside the curly bracket because just
a reactive
um oh sorry
we're doing
event reactive right event reactive we
listen to the button right
yeah okay so we're making this my bed
yeah my bad
that's okay but you were talking about a
reactive my brain was thinking about an
event reactive and between the two of us
we had
just something in between
yeah it was good it was good reactive
reactivity is not necessarily the most
intuitive thing
for god
yeah
great so that's that's good
and then comma curly and we'll do like
random dice val or something like that
like um
we can either just do the logic here we
can make the function somewhere else
and are you just thinking of like sample
one through six
one yeah and then we can get rid of the
assignment and just say sample one to
six one
oh so
yeah
perfect and let's get rid of the curly's
right where your your uh cursor is at um
because it's restoring it to the name
diceval not to the
um
so dice file open close on 14 delete the
open close
great
okay reuse the yes
reactivity pre-coffee
so this this should work
let's find out it's an event here all
right so when we click roll dice
theoretically what should happen is we
should get a printout of a number
let's just
there we go
i think we're getting all the numbers
beautiful all right we've rolled our
dice we get our number let's go to vegas
absolutely
um so let's uh actually
um
yeah so this works let's look at
can we do in like after line nine do
like
placeholders true
yes
and so that's just gonna lead like when
we restart up comma
listen first of all
great so there's just at least the box
yep so we're expecting as a user i'm
expecting something to show up there i'm
not just
looking like what happens when i push
the button theoretically i this is a
visual cue that something will pop out
there
see i do like a little bit of ui
a little bit yeah let's not go overboard
today
yeah that's no question
okay um all right so things work like
this is awesome
[Music]
so let's try to rewrite event reactive
without saying event reactive
how could we do this and let's not use
the the newer bind event let's actually
break it down to the primitives of
what's happening
we are essentially saying
dice val and we want to do this without
an event reactive so basically we're
saying what happens when
we run event reactive because event
reactive is like a wrapper
function
for some other things that are happening
under the hood and if i remember
correctly it's a
[Music]
it's not a reactive and an isolate is it
it is yes yeah it is okay
so
let's see so dice val is it reactive
um is that action
let's actually uh go back to our old app
and update it just a little bit
so that we can get some more um
reactiveness that isolate will show off
perfect um so let's add in uh after the
action button like
a slider or a numeric input um
that'll tell us like how many dice we're
gonna roll or like what's the highest
number on the dice
oh okay
i like the highest number because then
um
let's do let's see select
max
yeah
great
of the diet of the dice
die
and then we'll need a uh like a min max
and
selected and value yeah min is one
minute it'll be one max will equal
oh so
max would
i i'm trying to think of this is like
what the person is oh no nevermind we're
setting up our input so what what is it
is it 20-sided die
um step is one and uh
yeah value is six let's just start with
the
default small dice
great
and then we can listen to that in our
sample
um down in 26.
so sample
will be
uh
i think we can
uh
can i do one to
input
i think
sample.int is that something
um
but it's the same thing same concept as
where you're heading
sample dot
it is
yes
of n right so up to n
okay
so instead of
this we're gonna i'm just gonna comment
it out so we can see what we're working
with so you're saying sample.int
and we're gonna go
let's see n is a positive the number of
items to choose from so this would be
our
input
yep okay
um
no wait
yeah yep that is an input here and then
it is
it's a descriptive name but it's long
all right so that is the number that
they've selected
and then
size that's one
yes giving the number of it so size will
be one
right there anything else yeah there i
think we're good
yeah so that should be equivalent um you
could do one colon input dollar select
max number like that works fine as well
okay so you're saying here we could have
rewritten this as
sample
one two
input
select yes
yes okay
so if we were looking for something yeah
we'll just we'll keep that there if
people people want to see it so great so
this should
okay so everything runs
let's say instead of six and we do
expect it this is a bug we talked about
in our last video so we expect that you
can override it
and then we'll go over it nice so it is
more than six
which is good that at least is an
initial kind of unit test says to me
great it's working
nothing nothing's throwing up a red flag
i suppose there are edge cases we could
still work on etc but
this is a testing video
yeah
now it looks good um cool all right so
now we have this event reactive now we
ha and it listens to a button and on the
button click we sample a number for a
new dice roll perfect
the end result is dice val is a reactive
which we can then read later for the
render text
so okay
now it's here great i love it
so let's uh go down the route of
deconstructing back to the primitives of
just reactive and isolate okay and
observe if we need it but i don't think
so in this answer okay so we're going to
take
this right here everything that i've
just commented out and we're going to
break it up into an
a reactive and an isolate
yes okay so we're gonna call it the same
thing
and then when i'm thinking about a
reactive and an isolate
which one comes first does it matter
can i do both
like can i switch them or is like how
would i approach this if i'm thinking
about
so the answer that you're getting back
is a reactive and isolates occur in the
reactive expression
so it needs to be isolate needs to be
inside the curlies
okay so
if i'm getting ready to basically write
my own event reactive this would be my
starting place
that's pretty good yep okay so
isolate is inside my reactive um so i
need to think about what i'm isolating
and what i want to be reactive and we're
talking about reactive we're talking
about like responding to changes in the
ui
correct
so i would
let me think about this so what we had
here so there's the button um
and i'm guessing we want to isolate the
button click
okay we can write it out
i feel like i just walked into a trap
slightly
yes
okay
and then how are we handling 26
26 okay so
oh
wait a minute i would like to revise my
answer
because what i want is i want
to isolate
my sample int i want to basically say
like once we have this value
then pass it to
a
reactive okay
can i change it yeah absolutely
i mean like i know i can but if there's
a lesson to be learned
nah
it's uh you're seeing what's going to
happen so all right so we've handled 26
now how do we handle 23. yeah so would i
put that
kind of would i put that in here so
input
so that would be like very similar code
to event reactive yeah but reactive only
has one
like expression that it can take
okay got it so reactive
we put the curlys so that we can do
multi-line yep and then
does it oh
okay so input
i'm not sure that this does it does this
this isn't quite right i feel like uh so
the comma yeah the comma is not
necessary um because it's an expression
uh from 28 to 31
um and so input button will trigger
reactivity
but then we will isolate 30 and so we
will
use the value for select max number but
we will not
re-sample if the max number changes
oh
this is the answer this is okay
let's let's give it a shot see if it
works i was like wait what did i do
wrong this makes sense to me nah nah
everything's everything's spot on all
right so we have our initial value of
six oh it did roll for us so that's one
thing that's going on
uh okay um we can adjust that afterwards
that's a cool cool change
that was unexpected
so well i mean i guess some of you
expected it i didn't
um and then let's see if we can get this
guy we said we could go up to 20. great
we're rolling above 20 or above six
so i feel like our basic wiring is
intact um the one thing is that if i
reload it automatically rolls for me so
that is something that we do need a
little bit
do you have a quick idea on how to
address that i'm really hoping it's
wreck
it is wreck
can i just wrap input button one in rec
absolutely
because the default value for input
button one is
falsie it's zero
yeah so basically we're saying rec means
require
and so we're requiring that button to be
pushed so because the button hasn't been
pushed
nothing is rolling but now we can make
our changes and then when we push the
button we get
we have value
okay awesome
[Music]
all right so we've taken event reactive
we've broken it down
now which direction do you want to go
uh let's go to the
bind event so
we'll go to the other extreme and be
like how can we rewrite event reactive
to just use bind event and reactive
okay so i don't think i've used bind
event at all
so i'm really looking forward to this
um
so
where do we start how do i start
thinking about bind event
so let's let's look at the event
reactive just because it's very explicit
as to what's happening
um so event reactive has two situations
it has a i listen to this situation and
then i perform that
uh as another expression
and so
the perform that returns a reactive so
let's just make a reactive where we
sample the end
okay
so we're talking about
reactive
um
and then oh my goodness
sample ins
put select max
number
and then size equals one okay so we've
got that reactive awesome and we could
just you know let's run this app just to
see what it does
love it okay so
it works once
right so when i read the app it rolls
but the app is rolling for me and no
matter how many times i click the button
it will not re-roll
but if you change the max dice number it
will
all right so it's basically made my
button
useless
it's like a redundant button because all
i have to do is change the number
and i get a reroll so we're short
circuiting something in here
yes
so we need to we want to listen
to the button click and so we're going
to bind
to the event of the button click
okay and here's where i get to
i stopped mid sentence but i was like i
get to do a pipeable function
i get to do things
yeah i get to do and then i'm just going
gonna trail off
all right so i love the way that you
explain this right
we're gonna um we're gonna do the
sampling but we're gonna bind it to
this clicking of the button so if i run
this i'm
anticipating um
this will be fine this will say six and
this will be blank
let's hope
oh uh
we forgot to load
we should we go native pipe are you on
the latest you know i have never
used it so let's let's do both to show
that they're equivalent
i'm so scared i've never because this
should work theoretically yes
let me stop my app just because it
crashed so
look at that
all right
roll the dice it works
if i change it it's not changing on its
own it requires that that's great so
this
for everyone at home that is the the
base r pipe you can definitely use that
um if we want to use our
um kind of more tidy verse style pipe we
could do
library twitter
and then you can swap out this guy
for this
um these are all equip these are all
equivalent
right this right here is where we broke
down
into the primitive functions to get our
dice roll
and then this is using event reactive
which
accomplishes the same thing but people
might be more familiar with and then
this uses bind event so bind event is
new er newish
i mean in the history of shiny it's new
um are there situations where i don't
want to use find event or like where
bind event wouldn't be appropriate or is
it just kind of always there is a good
substitute or drop in for my event
reactive and my observe event
uh it's a good substitute i'd say it's
like the new school way
because
rather than having more and more
arguments you can just have more and
more decorators
um these extra functions
cool um so this is like the end of this
idea um i love it
but
i would love to go down the route of how
can we make a function of de-duping
and it kind of it might go towards
closures
it may not
let's get rid of like these guys yeah we
could get rid of those and
the the idea is that
i think we'll start the
uh
and we can talk about this but i want to
start the random dice roll at
um
like
three uh the max max height is three
and then that way it's like
i want a random number that isn't
uh so no that one's fine um we can keep
it there but
put the value at three
oh okay
and
the goal is like when you roll the dice
you never get the same number that you
had before like that's a requirement
oh okay so to deconstruct this a little
bit when i run sample i can set replace
equals true or replace equals false
right so i'm just running sample but
even though i'm doing a version of
flavor of sample here
even if i set replace equals false
because it's reactive
that behavior is going to be overridden
uh
yeah reactive will always return a new
it'll it'll uh send down saying uh
please
um
i can't think of the word brain fart uh
it's like it's like a fresh start for
sample men
every single time
yeah so even if i do let's see if we can
so replace won't matter because it's
size one um yeah
but uh
you could sample
uh you could call sample into like
two of size one and in like the console
and it will come with like the same
answer multiple times right possibly we
do
[Music]
sample int
input oh no there's no input just like
two two and then we said size equals one
and so okay we get two great and do we
do it again we get two again
and the reactivity would actually say
that that's a new value and it would
redraw it again
and that's fine
but um i don't want
uh
and now it finally goes to one so
the goal
for me is to more like what if we had a
deduper that said
every time you click the button um
uh
don't use any number that you've already
seen
uh or at least not the prior one
okay so we're saying you can never roll
okay so this is a great clarification
we're saying
you can re-roll
you can't re-roll the number that you
just ran
so we just have to look back one
yeah okay
yep
exactly okay so i thought it was like
okay if we have a six sided die
we basically
once we roll a number it's out and i
think my approach to that
i was like oh okay we'll just like store
those numbers somewhere
um but now we're doing something a
little different so okay i'm really
excited to see how you would approach
this let's let's do this so we do we're
just saying like if we have if we roll
two
we can roll
any number that isn't two
yes okay
so maybe we should bump our min to two
uh on the numeric because a min of one
wouldn't make sense we get forever true
that's true that's true oh look at you
thinking of edge cases right out of the
box
yeah
all
right forever
um
awesome okay cool
so
how um
how like do you have any crazy ideas on
how this might happen
um kind of what i'm thinking of is we
need some way to store the number that
we just rolled
great right r needs some way um to kind
of catch that number
so
there's i'm i'm thinking
it almost needs to be like this
temporary
assignment of
i can make it a reactive one
because any any time we're doing a value
that's according to user actions
typically it's a reactive
or reactive vowel uh in this case
okay so if you're doing a variable it's
now a reactive vowel
yeah so last world exists
and so now i'm thinking about there's
like a timing component to this that is
really interesting because if i just do
reactive veil
um
dice val
right those will be the same every time
i do them so there's i need to stagger
in some way so
for example uh i think this will work
because i haven't refreshed my code
right so i've rolled a three now i want
to store three
and remove it from like my possible
roles
fair let's let's try to go through this
a little bit more um
explicit but we could get smart with it
later yes um brute force it then clean
it up perfect
so 25
inside 25 you're saying you want to know
your previous value
and so let's let's retrieve like
current roll or
pre prep roll or something like that
okay so i have last roll and then would
i set this equal to current roll
uh that's like new roll
okay
i like that better
okay
and then so this is our new one
and then uh
we would be like while
new role doesn't or double equals last
roll
oh okay so well new role yeah so well
our new role sorry hang on
new role is equivalent to last roll we
want to keep rolling
uh last roll open and close because it's
a reactive foul
this is such a great example of
reactivity i mean i know you know that
oh it's this one it uh
let me know that you can really bank on
rules and it was really neat yeah um
right so we're just going to re-roll
until they're not equal
yep so we'll need to on 28 we'll need to
update your new role value
that's right um well new rule
is equivalent to last world and then
yeah so then
new raw
sampling
and then at the end of the reactive
expression we want to return the new
role values so we'll say return
or not return but um
uh just new role at the end
because it's the last value being yes
yes this is this also gets me all the
time but yeah
yes i think it actually works when you
say return but um it does
but we don't need to
we don't need to yes we could print we
could message we could do all kinds of
things there but we should be fine with
just this
so the default dice roll is three so
there's a high probability that you
would get the same number
um so if we click it like five six times
we should always
the goal is to always see a new number
all right so
we reloaded the app
let's see what happens
crash and burn um
so we need to maybe say
uh set something for last roll because
what's happening is it's saying like
while the new
int equals null
is what's happening on 27
so let's just
default it to like what do we want zero
well do we want to default it to zero
well zero's good because i was gonna say
let it roll
but i like zero better because zero is
not actually within our realm of
possibility
it's like not in our number set so and
it's much simpler than rerolling
yes
i like your approach better
so
we you could also do like if not null
last roll then do stuff
so yeah yeah but this will be faster
than i mean marginally faster but
we're not writing a big
this is much clearer though with some
abstraction all right so when we roll
the dice
we should never get the same number
twice
ah
made a rhyme
but we will
oh no oh no
what is happening this logically makes
sense to me
it does um but what we're missing the
final step
so now that we have a new role we need
to do what we need to replace the last
roll
there we go
so let's make a new reactivity
um
because that logic is solid so let's
keep it there okay and we're gonna uh
this is a side effect because we don't
care about the actual answer so we're
going to do
uh instead of a reactive we're going to
do a what
for side effects
oh i'm sorry observe events
uh yes observe event but we just learned
about find event
so let's try to write this as an observe
with
okay oh
okay so instead of observe event we're
going to do barrett look at you just
tying everything together
there it had the master plan i'm
literally along for the ride
all right so we should call do we want
to call this updated last roll
uh but we don't need the answer so it's
just going to be a plain observe
oh that's right right
you don't have to
you don't have to assign your observers
basically long and short of it i still
try though
all right so we are going to observe
um
would it be input button one
uh
nah i think we can just observe the dice
roll
okay so new roll or last roll
um
well
let's let's go ahead and pipe to the
bind event because then we can talk
about the two situations
so let's take the observe and then pipe
to bind event
all right let's get some formatting in
here
so
what are we wanting to do we are wanting
to update last roll when dice val is
updated all right so we basically want
to say last row equals new role
great so let's do that on 36 that's the
action that we're going to do so last
roll and then inside the parentheses
we'll say
um
new rule isn't accessible from here but
that's the value of diceval so let's
capture dice now
i really wish i had done dice val with
anyway underscore but that's okay
we can switch it's not too much but all
right let's see real quick real quick if
you're following along at home we've
just added an underscore
and then yeah so on 36 new roll
uh does not exist here and diceval will
be underscored and executed
all right it doesn't exist
would i super assign it
uh nope um so we'll just remove it um
because
we can't retrieve new role we can only
retrieve diceval
so let's execute diceval because dice
file right now is is a function
but if we execute it then we're
retrieving the reactive value
okay
great so this will update last row with
the value of dice file
so
real quick question is that equivalent
to saying last roll
um
no
because uh
that's so that's the
urge to do because we are uh
very familiar with variables where we
can say like a is 5
but to update a reactive vowel you need
to submit it to the function
so
the update method is inside last roll
and
yeah
so i kind of think of reactive valves as
a getter and a setter to get the value
you don't send anything to set the value
you send in something
okay um it's overloaded um
i like the idea of an arrow but uh
yeah it doesn't work because this is
more like where we're passing functions
to functions this is like a quirk of r
that we just yes
okay so it should work now right
uh but we need something in 40. oh shoot
that's right what are we going to bind
it to um
right otherwise it's just going to like
do its thing i'm guessing we're just
gonna bind it to input button one
so it may work um because we're
performing both actions when input
button executes
but there's a theoretical
uh edge case of what if
35 runs before 25 right because we have
to remember that shiny scripts don't run
line one to line whatever they don't run
in order they're more like dynamic right
um so
just because like it happened but
yeah so if observe runs first now we're
stuck
um
yeah so if 35 were to run before 25 then
that would be bad can i bind this to the
diceval function like diceval has to be
called yes diceval
awesome
i think this will work i'm gonna stop it
since i think i crashed it last time
we'll get a clean start okay
so we expect when we hit rolled ice
that we're going to
get not three
we're gonna just get like new numbers
here it should not be so one so i
shouldn't see one
got a two three
all right
look at that
that's so cool
i would have never this is such a great
example too because i was like oh bind
event would naturally bind to
almost what i would think of as like a
physical event like i'm clicking a
button or i'm seeing a physical change
but i can bind the event to a function
call
to any reactive value um any
any set of reactivity okay
and you can have i think you can have
rec statements in there
like
it's just think of it as what would we
do in the beginning of that
uh
reactive expression you can do lots of
logic you can hit lots of reactivity
all right
okay
i want to see what people do with this
i want to see
i want to see all kinds of things i want
to see what you can do with bind event
[Music]